or on problem 195 and they have drawn a
little bit of a grid here let me try to
draw it as well one two three and they
do the same thing the other direction
one two three and they call this first
Street of X there's actually four going
that direction let me try that one
so there's another street like that and
they call this first Street 2nd Street
3rd Street 4th Street and Avenue a B and
C and they say that this point right
here I'll do that in different color
that point right there is X and that
point right there is why Pat will walk
from intersection X to intersection Y
along a route that is confined to the
square grid of four streets and three
Avenue shown in the map how many routes
from X to Y can Pat take that that have
the minimum possible length so
essentially minimum possible length he
doesn't waste time right so let's think
about it this way so he could go you
could go this way so we could think
about how many different ways can he get
to each point on this graph right so to
get here to get there there's one way
right one possible way to get there this
seems to be a very very similar problem
with what I saw in a some computer
science exam a long long time ago but
there's one way to get there right
that's obvious so how many ways are
there to get here well you view it as
its well that you to go from this path
to this path and this path to this path
you can sum the two ways to get there so
it's 2 right which makes sense you go
like that or you could go like that how
many ways to go here
well there's only one way to go here
right likewise only one way to go here
now this is where it gets interesting
how many ways are there to go here right
I can either come from there and there's
and there's only one way to get there so
that
one path or I could come from here right
but there's two ways to get here so
there's two ways to get here via this
path and there's one way to get here
over here this path so there are three
ways to get here so essentially I just
added the one in the two and you think
of the same logic here how many ways are
there to get there well I can come via
this path and that'll be and two and
there's only one way to get here so
there's only one way to get from this
direction or I could come from this
direction but there's two ways to get
here so there's two ways to come from
this direction so there's three ways to
get from that direction right because
the same logic there's one way to get
here right you just go straight up how
many ways are there to get here well one
way to get there three ways to get there
so there are four ways to get here
because you can go through that one way
or through these three ways so really
how many ways are to get here you go
three ways to there three ways to there
and I can come from either here or here
so there are six ways right so how many
ways to get to why four ways to get here
six ways to get here 6 plus 4 10 ways to
get here right I could either come from
one of the six ways from this direction
or one of the four ways from this
direction so 10 ways and that is choice
C next problem 196 196 the ratio by
volume of soap to alcohol to water in a
certain solution so soap to alcohol to
water is equal to 2 - 50 - 100 the
solution will be altered so that the
ratio of soap to alcohol is doubled
while the ratio of soap to water is
halved so soap to alcohol will be
doubled and then the ratio or the ratio
of soap to alcohol is double in the
ratio of soap to water soap to water is
halved
okay if the altered solution will
contain 100 100 cubic centimeters of
alcohol of alcohol alcohol how many
cubic centimeters of water would contain
so let's think about what the new ratio
is the the old ratio of soap to alcohol
right the old ratio of soap to alcohol
soap to alcohol was to 250 now they want
to double this ratio right so the new
ratio of soap to alcohol is going to be
for 250 fair enough
now the old ratio of soap to water was
two to 102 to a hundred now what's the
new ratio of soap to water it was going
to be 1/2 right for that equals soap to
water but we want to have this ratio so
now the new ratio of soap to water is 1
to 100 right so let's see how we can
think about if we rewrite this the R if
we rewrite and let's write this as a
ratio of 4 to a something so that's the
same 1 to 100 is the same thing as 4 to
4 hundred right 4 to 400 so let's see if
we can rewrite these ratios so the ratio
of soap to alcohol soaked to alcohol to
water now becomes 4 250 and the ratio of
soap to water is 4 2 a 4 - 400 - 400 so
they give us alcohol and they want to
figure out water right so what's the
ratio of alcohol to the ratio of alcohol
to water is equal to 50 to 400 and
that's another way of saying 1 2 8 right
alcohol to water is equal to 1 to 8 let
me see if that's is 1 to 8 and they're
saying that we have a hundred cubic
centimeters of alcohol so how much water
so 100 over water
is equal to
one two eight and you can even eyeball
that that's 100 over 800 so water has to
be equal to 800 cubic centimeters and
that's choice e next question next
question
197 if 75% of a class answered the first
question on a test correctly so 75% so
let's say 3/4 question 1 correctly
question 1
55% answered the second question on the
test correct I'll let me write it this
way question 175 percent true question 2
55%
answer the second question correctly and
20% answered neither of the questions
correctly so 3 20 percent so that's not
question 3 20% neither what percent
answered both what percent answered both
correctly okay
so 3/4 answered question 1 correctly and
1/4 answered it incorrectly Q 1 they got
it wrong right now they're telling us
that 20% got neither correct so that
means that they got Q 2 wrong as well Q
2 was wrong as well and this is 20
percent of the entire population so this
is 1/5
this is 1/5 of the entire population so
my question is if this is 1/5 of entire
population what what fraction of this
population was it well of these people
the fraction that got it correct
we've got Q 2 incorrect let's write that
as X so x times 1/4 is equal to 1/5
multiply both sides by 4th to get X is
equal to 4/5 so what we know is since
this is 1/5 of the entire population
that of the people who got question one
incorrect 4/5 also got question two in
correct right and if you want to know
what percentage that is the whole
population melt why 1/4 times 4/5 and
you get 1/5 which is that data that they
had given us but this helps us because
this tells us of these people who got
question 1 incorrect what fraction got
it right got question - right well a 4/5
got it wrong
1/5 got question 2 correct
1/5 got question - correct
all right so now let me let me just take
a step back I don't I want to make sure
I'm not doing in the slowest possible
way they tell us that right
75% got question 1 right and then 55%
got question - right okay so let's think
about it so of this some percentage got
question 2 got question 2 wrong right
well actually let's think over this way
else of this some percentage got
question 2 right let's call this I don't
know let's call this Y right let's call
that Y and let's call this right here
let's call this and I already used well
I'm gonna use X again let's call this X
well yeah I'll use X this is a different
X all right so first of all what is the
total proportion of people who got
question 1 wrong and then question -
right what's 1/4 times 1/5 so it's 1 xx
of the people got question 1 wrong and
question - right and that's equal to X
now what percentage of the people got
question 1 right in question 2 wrong
well that's going to be Y right now if
you think about and Y is actually Y is
actually what we're solving for they
want to know how many students answered
both correctly right so if you think
about it y + 1 xx that represents all of
the people who answered question 2
correctly right all the people answered
question 2 correct line is a little
confusing are those people and those
people right that's all the question to
answer incorrectly we already know that
this is 1 xx of the population and we
know that Y
plus one twentieth of the population is
equal to fifty five percent of the
population so we could write that as
fifty five over a hundred or we could
divide both by five and you get 11 over
twenty this is eleven twentieth of the
population so what is y well subtract
one twentieth from both sides Y is equal
to eleven 20s minus 120 is equal to ten
xx which is equal to 1/2 so 1/2 of the
population got both the first and the
second question right and actually we
didn't even have to use well we did have
to use this 3/4 information to get this
1/4 here but anyway and let's see if
that's one of the choices right D 50%
and I'm all out of time see you in the
next video